With summer blockbuster season in full swing,
it's harder than ever to keep up with all
the new footage being released for upcoming
films.
New trailers are hitting the web every day
for movies you won't want to miss.
To help you keep track of everything Hollywood
has in store for us, here's a look at the
recently released trailers that will absolutely
blow you away.
First Kill
Hayden Christensen rushes to rescue his son
in the first trailer for First Kill, which
unites the former Star Wars actor with Bruce
Willis in an intense, action-heavy thriller.
The movie stars Christensen as a Wall Street
broker who brings his wife and son to a remote
cabin in the woods for a vacation—only for
his son to end up kidnapped, leading to him
teaming up with Willis' police chief to rescue
the boy.
Look for it July 21.
Brigsby Bear
Things get very weird very quickly in the
trailer for Brigsby Bear, a bizarre dramedy
starring Saturday Night Live's Kyle Mooney.
Mooney plays James, a man who's been the sole
audience member for the children's TV show
Brigsby Bear Adventures.
When the show ends, James sets out to give
the story an ending himself, but he must learn
to cope with an outside world he knows nothing
about.
Claire Danes, Mark Hamill, and Greg Kinnear
round out the supporting cast.
Kidnap
Halle Berry gets the Taken treatment in Kidnap,
in which she stars as Karla, a woman who goes
on a mission to rescue her son after he's
kidnapped at an amusement park.
The trailer ramps up into a high-stakes highway
chase with enough explosive visuals to leave
you ready to see more on August 4.
Detroit
This trailer for Kathryn Bigelow's upcoming
thriller Detroit features a tension-soaked
look at the Detroit riots in the summer of
1967.
John Boyega stars as a young security guard
caught in the aftermath of the Algiers Motel
incident, in which three young black men were
killed by police.
The trailer knows exactly when it should change
gears to keep viewers' hearts pumping, and
it looks like another powerful drama from
the director of the Hurt Locker.
Look for it August 4.
American Assassin
Teen Wolf vet Dylan O'Brien takes a much more
dramatic turn in American Assassin, playing
a young man who becomes a CIA-trained killer
after his girlfriend is murdered in a terrorist
attack.
Taylor Kitsch and Michael Keaton co-star in
this action thriller that looks like it hits
all the right notes.
The trailer teases the film's action and the
characters' motivations without giving too
much away, leaving lots for audiences to enjoy
when the movie arrives in September.
Stronger
Jake Gyllenhaal stars in Stronger as Jeff
Bauman, a real-life victim of the Boston marathon
bombing who lost both of his legs while waiting
for his girlfriend at the finish line.
Bauman published a memoir on his journey to
walk again, which serves as the basis for
the movie's script.
Gyllenhaal has repeatedly demonstrated a chameleon-like
ability to dissolve into his roles, and that
seems to be the case once again in Stronger.
The movie is sure to be a tearjerker, but
also promises to be an inspiring trip to the
theater.
Look for it on September 22.
American Made
Tom Cruise does Tom Cruise things in the trailer
for his upcoming action film American Made,
which features the star as real-life pilot
Barry Seal, a drug smuggler recruited by the
CIA to help fight against the communist threat
in Central America in the 1980s.
Cruise apparently flew all the planes for
real, even at one point stepping away from
the controls to film a stunt despite the fact
that he was totally alone in the aircraft,
because he's Tom Cruise.
The movie also reunites him with Edge of Tomorrow
director Doug Liman.
Strap in on September 29.
Flatliners
If you had reservations about the upcoming
Flatliners remake, this trailer should set
you at ease.
A new cast is featured this follow-up to the
'80s sci-fi flick, with Ellen Page, Diego
Luna, Nina Dobrev, James Norton, and Kiersey
Clemons taking over as the medical students
haunted by the dead after flatlining—experimenting
with dying for a few minutes before being
resurrected.
Although we're oversaturated with remakes
and sequels nowadays, Flatliners looks like
it has the potential to honor the original
while holding up on its own.
Take the plunge on September 29.
Marshall
Chadwick Boseman is a man on a mission in
the first trailer for Marshall.
The Black Panther star plays Thurgood Marshall,
the first African American Supreme Court justice,
seen early in his career as a young lawyer
fighting for justice on behalf of a black
servant accused of attacking his white employer.
Boseman seems like a safe bet to be a big
part of awards season conversations over the
next several years, and Marshall might just
bring him his first major nomination.
We'll see when it premieres on October 13.
The Foreigner
Jackie Chan shows off his dramatic side in
the first trailer for The Foreigner, a thriller
that finds the action star playing Quan, a
restaurant owner who's hellbent on revenge
after his daughter is killed in an IRA bombing.
The trailer makes it clear The Foreigner won't
skimp on the action, but the serious role
has a touch of Chan's Police Story roots—and
he proves he can still pull it off in this
clip.
Thank You For Your Service
Following three soldiers who struggle after
returning home from Iraq, Thank You For Your
Service delves into the weighty topic of PTSD
and its lasting effects on veterans.
The film marks the directorial debut of Jason
Hall, who was nominated for an Academy Award
for writing American Sniper.
The movie is sure to be heavy, but for viewers
looking for timely, thought-provoking drama,
it's guaranteed to pay heartbreaking dividends.
Look for it on October 27.
Murder on the Orient Express
The first trailer for the upcoming mystery
movie Murder on the Orient Express starts
with a scream.
Based on the bestselling Agatha Christie novel,
the movie's all-star cast, including Willem
Dafoe, Daisy Ridley, Michelle Pfeiffer, Penelope
Cruz, Judi Dench, Kenneth Branagh, and Johnny
Depp, should be enough to make you want to
head out for a mysterious night at the movies.
Take the ride on November 10.
Daddy's Home 2
Will Ferrell and Mark Wahlberg are back in
Daddy's Home 2, the sequel to their hit 2015
comedy.
Only this time, the pair have some extra help
from Mel Gibson and John Lithgow as their
dads.
The trailer features some standout funny moments
from Ferrell and Wahlberg, but the real stars,
despite their brief screen time, are Lithgow
and Gibson.
Check out the absurdity on November 10.
Coco
Pixar is back to tug on your heartstrings
again with Coco, a film that follows Miguel,
a young boy who accidentally travels to the
Land of the Dead.
The trailer doesn't give away many details,
instead opting to use uplifting music and
bright visuals to highlight the film's humor
and heart.
Even if it doesn't reveal much, Coco's trailer
should be more than enough to get Pixar fans
young and old excited for the movie's November
22 release.
Jumanji: Welcome to the Jungle
Jack Black plays a teenage girl in Jumanji:
Welcome to the Jungle, so you know it's going
to be interesting.
Taking place in the same universe as the first
Jumanji film, it sees four teenagers transported
into the world of a magical video game, where
they find themselves stuck in the bodies of
the game's characters.
While the trailer doesn't explain much of
the story beyond the premise, it does tease
a ton of action and one-liners and suggests
that this Jumanji could be a game worth playing…
and a movie worth watching.
Head into the jungle on December 20.
The Greatest Showman
It's easy to buy Hugh Jackman as the inventor
of show business in the first trailer for
his upcoming musical The Greatest Showman.
Jackman steps into the role of P.T.
Barnum, the man who defined show business
as we know it through his founding of the
Barnum and Bailey Circus.
The Greatest Showman trailer uses Jackman's
inherent charm to gloss over some of the seedier
aspects of Barnum's story, but while it may
not be historically accurate, it does promise
a dazzling reminder of the power of the human
spirit.
Watch it Christmas Day 2017.
Black Panther
Wakanda is officially our new favorite location
in the MCU after the gorgeous Black Panther
trailer, which introduces live-action audiences
to the mysterious country for the first time.
Chadwick Boseman finally steps into the solo
spotlight, his supporting cast is stunning,
and the costuming and gorgeous visuals immediately
put the movie in an MCU league of its own.
The only thing wrong with this trailer: the
movie doesn't come out until February 2018.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!